Let's go to the phones at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty.
Let's see if it's a good phones day or a bad
phones day.
Six one seven eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
Starting with our caller from the five one
six area code.
Who's calling today from five one six.
Hey, is that me?
Yeah.
Who's this?
Hi, I'm Nick from New York.
Nick from New York.
What's going on, my friend?
So I would like to know what is the plan to
stop Trump from suppressing the vote in November?
I wish I knew.
I mean, listen.
So there's a couple different things going
on here.
And it's like you've got the paramilitaries
in Portland and soon likely to be other cities
possibly they will remain to intimidate into
November.
You've got Trump trying to prevent vote by
mail, which is really just expanding absentee
ballots.
You've got, you know, all of the players that
want to interfere in the election still plan
to, you know, Russia, possibly China, etc..
I think the plan has to be we overwhelm with
the vote by so much that the interference
doesn't matter.
I mean, I hate to say it, but I don't know
what the plan is.
Nick.
That's a great idea, though.
I mean I mean, I hope it works.
I hope we do get this president out of office
because he's so incompetent.
Yeah.
Are you what state.
So do you vote in New York?
I'm actually too young to vote.
I'm 17.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, that's OK, unfortunately.
If you could vote, though, you would not vote
for Trump.
It sounds like I would totally vote for Biden.
Got it.
OK.
And so are you are you between high school
and college right now?
Are you about to be a senior?
I'm about to be a senior.
And what's are you going back for in person
or is it virtual classes?
I have no idea.
You just you still don't even know.
Yeah, I don't know.
Yeah.
What would you prefer?
Well, I would.
I mean, I'm OK with either one.
Obviously, I'd rather go in first and you
would say.
And you'd what, you'd wear a mask, you'd be
OK with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You do your parents have strong feelings one
way or the other.
What what do you say?
Do your parents have a strong feeling about
whether they want you physically in school?
I don't know.
I would have to ask them.
All right, Nick.
Very good.
Glad you're paying attention to the voter
suppression.
It's going to be a big deal.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you so much for taking it.
All right.
Take care.
Nick from New York got right to the question.
I love it